Bruno Darwin est avec nous bonjour Bruno
merci d'être là est-ce qu'on peut
imaginer un instant Bruno et pour faire
avec quoi est-ce que disait l'instant
Yann stonton Berg que le Kremlin c'est
peut-être qu'il ne peut la plus la
gagner cette guerre mais qu'il tente de
la rendre complètement
invivable insupportable oui visiblement
c'est la stratégie employée actuellement
par le Kremlin dont les troupes
effectivement sont en difficulté sur le
terrain l'hiver va peut-être geler les
fronts le front les front en fait de
part et d'autre sur 1200 km au total et
effectivement parallèlement depuis
quelques semaines et bien la Russie
bombarde non seulement les fils
ukrainiennes mais aussi et surtout donc
les infrastructures énergétiques et pas
simplement d'ailleurs les centrales
électriques ça va jusqu'au station de
transformation à haut voltage qui
permettent la distribution de
l'électricité donc en fait c'est quand
même un calcul délibéré de viser
l'ensemble de la chaîne de la production
à la distribution notamment
d'électricité et ça effectivement c'est
considéré par l'OTAN et pas seulement
par le temps mais là ça a été l'occasion
de le rappeler comme des crimes de
guerre puisque là l'agresseur la Russie
s'en prend directement aux populations
civiles qui ne sont pas impliqués
directement dans le conflit et il faut
savoir quand même que la pluie missile
que la Russie fait sa battre à peu près
tous les 13 14 15 jours sur l'Ukraine on
s'attend une prochaine vague bientôt a
déjà quand même endommagé 25 à 30% de
l'infrastructure des infrastructures
énergétiques en Ukraine d'où cette
mobilisation de l'OTAN qui dit qu'il
faut absolument aider le gouvernement
ukrainien et les autorités compétentes à
faire en sorte de réparer tout ça parce
qu'effectivement les températures on l'a
vu commence à être très froide l'hiver
approche et les États-Unis notamment
vont annoncer parallèlement va y avoir
aussi une rencontre des pays du G7 et
les États-Unis vont annoncer une aide
importante en matière énergétique à
l'Ukraine et invite les autres pays du
G7 affaires de même donc ça c'est un peu
les gestes concrets qui devraient être
annoncé dans 30 minutes une heure
maintenant et après il y a quand même la
posture pour faire passer le message à
Vladimir Poutine l'hiver approche on a
bien vu ta stratégie
le message c'est sache que
on sera aux côtés de l'Ukraine même si
c'est dur et d'un point de vue
énergétique d'un point de vue aussi
humanitaire pratique presque avec les
vêtements chauds etc et puis bien sûr on
va poursuivre dans le domaine militaire
avec notamment alors c'est ce que
réclame l'Ukraine ça a commencé à être
fait mais peut-être ça va être
approfondi la livraison de de domicile
solaire qui permettent d'arrêter quand
même ces missiles russes qui viennent
frapper les infrastructures civiles
ukrainiennes faut savoir que lors de la
dernière fois par exemple la Russie sera
attirante
il y en a 51 c'est à dire quand même les
deux tiers qui ont été d'ores et déjà
interceptés par l'école évidemment ça a
un impact directement sur la population
civile et l'autre volet de cette réunion
a initié lancé par l'OTAN Bruno c'est le
processus d'adhésion de la Suède et de
la Finlande qui a été largement
contrariée par la Turquie oui alors il
faut rappeler je Willy on l'a dit enfin
c'est une réunion des ministres des
Affaires étrangères là aujourd'hui de
l'OTAN à Bucarest et effectivement en
marge donc du dossier principal qui est
l'Ukraine il y a c'est un dossier
évidemment hautement connexe il y a la
question de l'adhésion à l'OTAN de la
Suède et de la Finlande on sait que le
pays membre de l'OTAN qui ne voulait pas
voilà on voit la carte voilà des pays de
l'OTAN et donc les deux candidatures ont
cours là-haut celui à déferlande alors
le pays qui ne voulait pas c'est hop là
c'est la Turquie
voilà alors les choses progressent un
tout petit peu
qui a eu un déplacement des ministres
suédois finlandais en Turquie se sont
engagés à faire mieux comme le demande
en carats c'est-à-dire pour lutter
contre l'activisme des Kurdes parce que
c'est toujours cette obsession du pkka
et accessoirement des epégé en Syrie
donc voilà c'est un peu progressé là ils
vont se rencontrer à nouveau aujourd'hui
en marge de cette réunion ça a
certainement pas débloqué la Val de la
Turquie mais disons qu'on est sur la
bonne voie seulement ça va pas se faire
tout de suite pour l'instant sur les 30
pays de l'automne il y en a 28 qui ont
ratifié le fait que la Turquie et la fin
la Suède et la Finlande seront les deux
prochains membres de l'OTAN donc il y a
toujours deux pays quand même qui n'ont
pas fait la Turquie donc et aussi la
Hongrie de Victor @ alors Victor hormone
c'est pas du tout pour les mêmes raisons
il dit simplement que le temps que le
processus législatif se fasse bref le
Parlement hongrois va ratifier ces
l'adhésion mais ce sera pas avant le
début de l'année évidemment les mauvais
esprits soulignent quand même la
proximité qui perdure entre Victor urban
et Vladimir Poutine et disent qu'en fait
Victor urban ne pouvant pas tellement
faire autrement cherche en fait à gagner
du temps au profit de Vladimir Poutine
merci beaucoup